citizens of the reject Nation will do a
core style citizens of the reject Nation
get that foreground we are here to do a
movie reaction for film when I was going
through a list of Coy's movies he hasn't
seen and I was like koi
glad it's on your list because it's been
online we're gonna do a movie reaction
to Kung Fu Panda today baby and if this
goes well maybe we'll do the sequels who
knows it all depends on you guys so you
know what to do you gotta you know kapow
that like button is that racist doesn't
matter this whole movie maybe kapow
like button also subscribe and click the
notification Bell if you want us to see
the next Kung Fu Panda movie follow this
man on the socials ain't that right koi
Sun at quite chandro that might be
racist
well koi son and questionable we're just
making jokes people as always fully
threats and watch the long story sync up
with your own copy of Kung Fu Panda
available for super sexy rejects cover a
whole bunch of stuff exclusively over
there speaking of our patreon most of
our videos uh feed through Vimeo over
there and uh recently we've got a crazy
Hefty bill from Vimeo for uh too much
bandwidth so with that in mind today's
video sponsor fellow Space Cadets it's
time to blast off into the final
frontier with the help of today's video
sponsor Star Trek Fleet command today's
video sponsor I've been playing this
game for the last 90 minutes so you bet
your buttocks I am ready to talk about
this game this free to play open world
MMO game puts you in the captain's chair
of your very own star base on the front
lines of a Star Trek universe where you
can construct fleets of your favorite
chips and recruit legendary officers to
your crew explore strange new worlds
seek out new life and civilizations and
dominate the Galaxy with your powerful
Starships with the ability to customize
your Fleet and set your sights on
expanding your territory eliminating
Rivals explore important resources and
exploring New Frontiers this game is the
perfect way to Unleash Your Inner Kirk
or Picard or data or many of the other
100 characters you can populate your
Fleet with imagine
commanding alongside your favorite
officers and living out all your space
exploration fantasies it's enough to
make a frenzy grin from ear to ear I
pulled that one so get beamed up reject
Nation join the millions of players
already exploring the Galaxy building
their fleets and competing in Space
Battles click the link in the
description box or scan the QR code
right here on screen to download Star
Trek Fleet command today and boldly go
where no one has gone before I wanted to
pun-centric it a little bit you know
[Music]
hope this movie is as good as it's hyped
up to be Legend Tales of a legendary
Warrior whose kung fu skills were the
stuff of Legend
[Laughter]
s
I think it will be
I see you like to chew
you should chew on my fist
and then he spoke enough talk let's
fight
cool
he was so deadly in fact that his
enemies would go blind from overexposure
to pure awesomeness
and attractive how can we repay you
there is no charge for awesomeness or
attractiveness that's what we say about
us every day way to steal Earth bit Jack
Black
[Music]
no one told me how cool this looks oh my
God
these heroic heroes in all of China the
furious five
bowed in respect to this great Master we
should hang out
so pretty and that's so get up you'll be
late for work what
that's the animation I'm familiar with
all right I was like does the whole
movie
I was in the two
I used to know how to do that used to do
it without hands oh monkey mantis green
viper Tigress
a pig and a panda
sorry Dad sorry it doesn't make the
noodles that cannot be his biological
father will we address it probably not I
hope they do
adopted my geese I was dreaming about uh
noodles my son not finally having the
noodle dream
you are almost ready to be entrusted
with a secret ingredient of my secret
ingredient soup
but Dad didn't you ever want to do
something else I thought about running
away and learning how to make tofu
this is about chasing your dreams koi
like us being on YouTube that's what we
always wanted to do everything's been
accomplished by us
I dreamed of Vimeo but it was expensive
for me
[Music]
they're real they are real yeah
well done students like Splinter mantis
Master Chief what it's masterway he
wants to see you
you summoned me is something wrong
whoa I really like the teacher having
weird little like after effect Mudders
like he always looks exasperated detail
why must something be wrong for me to
want to see my old friend so nothing's
wrong well I didn't say that you think
he's a villain he moves awfully slowly I
don't need a whisper we have microphones
I have had a vision
will return
still that's the villain
we have to do something we can't just
let him march on the valley and take his
revenge your mind is like this water my
friend when it is agitated it becomes
difficult to see but if you allow it to
set a word if I like that metaphor the
dragon scroll who is worthy to be
trusted with the secret to Limitless
power to become the Dragon Warrior
I don't know
to the trade Palace one of the five is
gonna get the dragon scroll we've been
waiting a thousand years for this just
foreign
will be there and you'll sell noodles to
all of them that's tough when your
father's a goose have to live in a
shadow of a silly goose so it goes very
well done
[Applause]
it's like John mc4
[Music]
you're a fat Panda whenever I choose
will not only bring peace to the valley
but also to you
I wonder if there's some riffs on like
the Chinese zodiac oh that'd be
interesting 12 animals
[Music]
huh
oh need a thousand tongues of Fire
foreign
[Music]
a lot of pigs in this world
wow yeah
two bunnies
oh
[Music]
this poor guy
ah he found him the Force Master Oogway
will now choose the Dragon Warrior
does one of the furious five think
they're about to be selected I think so
because he sensed it and then who else
would be a thousand years I'm going to
see the
noodle dream I lied I don't dream about
noodles dad
I love kung fu
[Music]
H
go through the hole oh that's even
better
foreign
[Music]
movie now how interesting Master are you
pointing at me
him this is not a woke movie Tigress
has brought us a dragon warrior what
what what what what I like how his dad
just got in the door opens what
hey
stop wait
the voice of that little was a hamster
order
I'll say what is he you were about to
pointed tigers and that that thing fell
in front of her that was just an
accident there are no accidents is it a
red panda the little guy yeah I don't
know Fox the internet's like yeah
we have failed you no if the panda has
not quit by morning then I will have
failed you he's gonna try to force the
panda to quit I don't trust him sabotage
the band the destiny of a thousand years
this was a family wholesome movie come
on that mysterious creature we can't
name is Sir duplicitous double the guard
extra precautions
may not be adequate you doubt my
prison's security Shifu does
that Ving Rhames yeah it sounds like it
one way in One Way Out one thousand
guards and one prisoner really building
up this Baddie we have Thanos level
turnaround moment coming I think because
he visits he gets out fate or they find
an empty cage I'm just gonna wait right
here
it's nothing to worry about it's
perfectly safe or Michael Clark Duncan
oh maybe I'm gonna tell Shifu he's got
nothing to worry about
please go now
well let's see those eyes come on
Hannibal lectric cat
oh now he's got a tool
[Music]
oh because he visited
I do appreciate all the Kung Fu tropes
in here okay cinematropes
oh
I think the darker animation and the
like the exposure and contrast on them
is very striking the lighting's really
cool the sword of Heroes said to be so
sharp you can cut yourself just by
looking ow
[Music]
the invisible trident
[Laughter]
well done I
Jack Black is perfect I know I think his
voice work actually Blends really well
said to contain the souls of the entire
ten shoe Army have you finished
sightseeing would you turn around
hey how's it going now how do you get
five minutes oh no you what have
you done someone broke that but I'm
gonna fix it I'll I'll do you have some
you will never be the Dragon Warrior
until you have learned the secret of the
Dragon scroll who is this voice I can't
pinpoint it it's the whisper it's
throwing me off
those are sensitive in the flabby Parts
belly
[Music]
listen Oogway said that I was
you must know what happens when I flex
my pinky no
this part is clean
[Laughter]
I love animation tropes of the littlest
people being the most deadly and the
pinky line was perfect for building his
whole power yeah
hmm
sweet Diggity I love that a praying
mantis is one of the Mighty Warriors
the way they zero in on the unique way
the animals move is creative yeah you
buy their physicality because they're
actually using the anatomy of them yeah
let's just start at zero level zero
there is no such thing as level zero we
use that for training children he's got
a Sinister way of talking just hit it
how's that
[Music]
I
thought he might have accidentally
mastered it but no oh
[Music]
no
oh how did I do there is now a level
zero
perfect voice encouraging The Joy Jack
Black is having the sound he sounds like
Dustin Hoffman but does Dustin Hoffman
do voice over work
sounds like evil does nothing like James
Wood or something
Ed Harris
I know one of them's Jackie Chan and one
of them Seth Rogen I know that much we
definitely haven't heard Seth Rogue he's
gonna be the Mantis
[Music]
I've had a long and rather disappointing
day so uh oh
David Cross
yes I'm such a big fan outnumbered a
thousand to one but you didn't stop and
then you just okay
oh stop breaking stuff
we got big things tomorrow all right
you're awesome last thing I'm gonna say
okay to be shunned by Your Heroes
I don't know if Keanu was you don't
belong in the Jade Palace you're a
disgrace to Kung Fu and if you have any
respect for who we are you will be gone
by morning
damn that's a hot tiger
she's got that like goofy moving girl
thing yeah but I'm married I mean
couldn't touch the Tiger
that's the first problem
you eat when you are upset mood
been there I mean I'm not like the five
ah maybe I should just quit and go back
to making noodles quit don't quit
noodles don't noodles I love this
freaking Turtle he's the best at his
little shakes yeah there's a saying
yesterday
history
tomorrow's a mystery street but today
gift that is
present
he wrote The Turtles dialogue is that
from this movie
change society no
[Music]
[Applause]
that one feather that's all it took oh
no what's happening oh no
oh my God Lord of the Rings mobilize the
Thousand rhinos
[Applause]
man you guys suck a hitting an idol
object oh my god oh you're helping him
out
[Music]
scared a path uh clever so Batman should
have done Dark Knight Rises archers
[Music]
that's gorgeous that was awesome
all right he's threatening I'm worried
[Music]
it's good
it's like comic book panels the
choreography is so cool
wow they have to destroy this whole
place just to take him down it's the
balrog
[Music]
oh my God
foreign
[Music]
no rhinos were harmed in the making of
this movie they were ready
what if he's Jackie Chan yeah great his
talents are underrated then
fly back there and tell them
the real dragon warrior is coming home
oh that's a machine oh 100 yeah
yeah
great transition they got a great handle
on the action it's stunning
he's quit
you're not a real master if you're this
is your attitude man yeah it's gonna
make him better too what are you doing
here I thought I'd warm up a little
you're stuck stuck not laughs
[Applause]
it's a flap I love it it takes years to
develop one's flexibility and years
longer
foreign
[Music]
he has flappable optimism
[Laughter]
fourth
opponent's weakness and make him suffer
for it oh yeah
holy crap don't worry master I will
never quit
[Music]
hmm
he's not gonna quit is he he's not gonna
quit bouncing tell you that
yeah who am I to judge a warrior based
on his size I mean look at me
I'm over here
Sam oh hung you know Sama hungs huge guy
huh there was once a time when Master
Shifu actually used to smile
before Tai Lung the first ever to master
the Thousand Scrolls of kung fu oh my
God Thailand's like Darth Vader oh he
was the chosen one yeah
he's Obi-Wan Robin all and he raised him
as his son
I would get rid of that kid right away
that's it and when the boys showed
talents in kung fu
trained him oh he made him the murder he
is today he wanted the dragon scroll but
Oogway saw darkness in his heart and
refused outraged Tai long laid waste to
the valley I see outrage in your heart
no I don't I'm gonna Slaughter everyone
[Music]
oh five point Palm technique Turtle
style Shifu loved Tai Lung like he had
never loved anyone before
[Music]
oh she can never get his approval oh
that's why she's such a pain in the ass
it's for Hope for
and he's stuck with you a big fat Panda
who treats it like a joke
oh that is it my fault I accidentally
tweaked his facial nerve
he was such a good kid slightly
predictable landed though Zang I could
use some good news right now
the panda will never fulfill his Destiny
nor you yours until you let go of the
illusion of control you could learn
something from this movie boy
nope I want to do things my way
I am perfect
who just need to believe
oh he's gonna die I will try
good
no I think they kill the turtles so and
they have to prove and believe and
he becomes Master see how it's happening
it's happening
right now
as we speak oh no he's getting force
ghosted you can't leave me oh
what do we needed the most
cherry blossom is real pretty though
ah returning to energy man that's my
favorite character he was great the
turtle tortoise either one both great I
hope you like it
wow you're a really good cook I wish my
mouth was bigger Tigers you've got to
try this that's Jackie Chan okay
Master Shifu
you'll never be the Dragon Warrior
maybe someday you will have your ears
like mine that's good
ears
of course it's Shifu what do you think
I'm doing
Thailand has escaped from prison and
you're acting like children Master
Oogway will stop him not anymore let us
stop Tai Lung this is what you've
trained us for no you're not even gonna
talk about the dead turtle
hope you didn't love them
trying to get rid of you if you stayed
yeah every time you threw a brick at my
head it hurts
but it could never hurt more than it did
every day of my life just being me
oh that's really sad because
me could give me
[Music]
China wow
how are you gonna change this into the
Dragon Warrior
you don't look confident how I don't
know
must be like one of those activation
switches within him yeah like learn one
thing Powers no like the yeah awaken
something in him kind of thing I like
that shift in Conflict that's really
interesting because now they both want
the same thing with just dialogue
this is what you trained me for oh she
just got done solo
good team guys stopper we're not trying
to stop you what we're coming with you
no you're all gonna die
some great music transitions are so cool
too I got nipple chills my nipples got
hardcore I mean that happens to great
music you gotta feel it
the music is also backed by some gray
scene worth there that's gonna um
hahaha
he's motivated by food oh the peach tree
genius
what they thought was as big as weakness
with his strength yeah this movie's not
fat shaming it's that emboldening that
strengthening I just thought you might
be monkey he hides his almond cookies on
the top shelf
genius
don't tell a monkey
look at you yeah I know I disgust you
and yet you are 10 feet off the ground
and have done a perfect spread
there are no accidents you're damn right
I feel like you get cramps all the time
though if you have to be using food 20
minutes after you swim come on yeah well
you can't just eat and fight someone
this is the birthplace of kung fu
[Music]
I see it do you want to learn kung fu
yeah and I am your master okay
[Music]
don't cry
I thought Jack Black would be way more
over the top of his voice So Perfect
it's actually like more sincere than I
expected
[Music]
awesome bow reflexes it's actually
Harkens back to a lot of like old kung
fu movies I've seen the Montage or the
specific moves the way the Montage is
going in the placement of like using
food as a motif oh I like that it's a
jagger chamber called Fearless hyena
I love a good Improvement Montage
[Music]
look at him go look at him go muscle
memory learning
he's becoming the cool animation yeah I
vowed to train you and you have been
trained you are free to eat
hey
you are free to eat am I are you
Free Yourself
[Music]
yes yes that's what I thought they do I
love it
oh
no
oh come on you can beat him
look how happy he's becoming
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'm not hungry that type scene I've seen
that's definitely like Jackie Chan like
Copland and yeah Rumble in the Bronx era
cut it
oh you take him on one-on-one what is
the Dragon Warrior oh so that is his
name love how they gave Jackie Chan
barely any lines
how creative so cool Dynamic 3D
[Applause]
oh wow so smart crane where are you
[Music]
pray mantis
there you go
this guy's ferocious
[Applause]
[Music]
cool
ah that teamwork
yeah that was sick well they've slowed
him down which is nice the team Dynamic
was so cool there yeah
[Music]
they did not slow him down at all nope
told you well
oh no
everything
he just murdered the whole team are they
done no
oh
Frozen
paralyzed he could have killed
didn't he so you could come back here
and strike fear into our hearts but it
won't work uh it might
it might
I'm just one knee but you will have the
one thing that no one else does
dumplings
[Music]
oh get in the scroll
summon shenzhou
oh I love that that's fantastic a single
cherry blossom you will feel the
universe in motion around you wow can I
punch through walls
huh Focus he's like Miss Marvel
yeah
Ernest Kamala Khan energy it's blank
what okay look no put it on fire
Evacuate the valley what about you
master I will fight him what I can hold
him off long enough for everyone to
escape defeat be doth I'm very proud to
have been your master
don't sell yourself one that you've got
and you're gonna die you can't go in
thinking I'm going to die it's going to
become a Force ghost
[Music]
good to have you back son
I think this Goose made it with a panda
vegetables classic structure man
or do you think the character is going
to go back to their where they were at
the beginning but no they don't they
can't they've evolved they've changed
even if the world hasn't sometimes I
can't believe I'm actually your son
Paula I think it's time I told you
something I should have told you a long
time ago it doesn't realize he's adopted
he's a panda the secret ingredient of my
secret ingredients
but nothing yeah he made it that is
what's on the scroll I was right
to make something special you just have
to believe it's special
so the mcu's nothing
depends who you ask which part of the
internet
oh essentially your dad you're punching
in the face you knew I was the Dragon
Warrior but when Oogway said otherwise
what did you do shark your shoulders
nothing you were not meant to be the
Dragon Warrior who drove me to train
until my bones cracked who denied me my
destiny
I like the dream dream parallel with the
dads
oh that was awesome amazing yes amazing
give me the scroll I would rather die
oh where are you wow
[Music]
holy
tell me how proud you
boo
tell me
[Music]
kamehame I like how there's a sense of
improvisation to the fighting yeah but
still style like they are very unique I
have always been proud of you
and it was my pride
that Blinded Me I loved you too much to
see what you were becoming you could
learn a lot from this movie from him
yeah loving something too much
can't see it's probably won't let him
see the message
forest trees
[Music]
oh you will never see that
I am the Dragon Warrior Kim he's a panda
do you have a panda
it's better you're bad
you want it come get it
finally there you go
oh
[Music]
crush your instincts
everyone wow
[Music]
it's like drunken Warrior Twitter
exactly I was thinking like drunken
masters kind of fighting just the free
flow chaos yeah
great everything is learned
[Music]
[Laughter]
the camera work
it's so gorgeous how old is this movie
yeah feelings could have come out like
recently
three of them the power of the Dragon
scroll is mine
it's nothing there is no secret
ingredient it's just you
[Music]
that was unhelpful
oh he's too big he's too big
the anatomy
[Music]
very drunken mask
and the joy is why you have to have Jack
Black
[Music]
[Laughter]
I worked sumo
[Music]
he's dead
you're just a big
fat Panda
I'm not a big fat panda
I'm the big fat Panda
yes you're bluffing Shifu didn't teach
you that nope I figured it out
[Music]
there's like Jack Black says that I
think is from this is it unlike the
other 1800s
[Music]
broth runs in his blood
he saved the pigs and the bunnies they
get saved the pigs and the bunnies this
town is only full of pigs and flies
the occasional Goose
[Applause]
Warrior is my son biologically there are
no other pandas in this town
[Music]
oh
that's hitting
the Lord still has like this shittiest
stamina there's no cardio
[Laughter]
I defeated Tai long you did why wow
it's still surprised wow you have
brought peace to this Valley and to me
thank you you can't die too everybody
can't die they're sequels
oh what is he really gonna die too
no no
I am simply at peace
oh so um I should stop talking
if you can
oh it's cute uh the dragon reflected in
the water oh I love that you wanna get
something to eat
hi yeah that was so good
all right see who everyone is
it is
did not hear it
oh oh yes yes yes I remember that now
she has a warrior voice there it is very
obvious
Donkey Kong
which I haven't seen yet Lucy Lou
Jackie Chan Herbert Shanghai Knights
David Cross very recognizable voice
Randall duck Kim
oh yeah yeah
James Hong
that one's driving me nuts
was Michael Clarke Duncan okay
17 line Jackie Chan he barely gave him
Eddie lines Jackie Chan watching for
Jack like the year of the monkey needed
the respect I mean it's the it's Jack
chance so much inspirational sure came
from some like I know Jackie Chan didn't
really do too much
like Kung Fu fantasy right but like the
basis of a lot but there's a lot of yeah
Hans Zimmer music it was super cop not
Copland but I was driving me crazy this
whole time super cops the movies I love
yeah the music was stunning
I wonder who shot it
like cinematography by
e
I feel like there's a time when they
wouldn't credit the cinematographer and
animated movies
because uh
what's his name deacons did the Arthur
the art director because deacons did
Rango and that was before this
that's different they did a lot of mocap
for that oh that's true but the drains
are all very Deacon no there is there is
like cinematography involved and I feel
like there was a time where they
wouldn't make that explicitly clear and
animation because it it was so visual
because yeah you gotta like direct this
shits too yeah like you built it and
then
man that was a pretty film
thanks to all these folks
this song didn't make the Billboard top
100 like Mario's did
Jack Black's a tracking artist now
it's amazing
oh is this Jack Black singing the cover
oh it is yeah I hear it now because he
did that song Peaches and he made the
Billboard charts
that's Mario you'll know when you see
Mario
Dan fogler man doing for a while
when was this
Let Me Assume if there's a post credit
scene
Kung Kyle Gas good I'm glad he got in
here
Fu Panda Wayne Knight was the king boss
host
credit scene
I feel like there has to be there is an
after credit okay we will wait it out
that way the and we'll we'll talk in the
meantime we're gonna talk anyway
uh so I loved it
hi opinion I I personally feel I was a
little worried at first well not the
very beginning the very beginning I was
like this is stop smackingly gorgeous
and then there was like a 10 minute
window where I was like is this for me
and then it immediately wasn't it stayed
for me
so a late First Act a little bit of a
pacing issue but then I was I was struck
from two and three
yeah eventually Broach is passed like
this is just a kid's movie yeah it got
through it yeah like they did that we
have to make the kid movie like set up
and then they let us play yeah because
while like there's some funny moments in
here I mean there's a lot of jokes that
are very much obviously intentionally
aimed at like children and to be family
friendly uh as it ought to be you know
like does sometimes I feel like there's
like certain animated movies where the
comedy is just like so clever yeah so
good and this doesn't quite go there for
me but the comedy's not the real star of
this movie the star of this movie is the
animation the action scenes and there
was like just enough funny moments for
me to keep me engaged but the movie is
also where it's hard on the sleeve the
whole time like there is so much heart
with its characters throughout it had
more Ted lasso than a comedy for me it
was just like warm yeah there was a lot
of just like joy and it was a
celebration of Joy Jack Black was
celebrating Joy the Victor was the one
that like fought with joy yeah and I was
surprised I really was surprised by how
they got all these celebrity performers
in here and a lot of the times when you
hear celebrity performers
they're stiff and I'm more aware of who
the celebrity is agreed but their voices
really did match well for these animals
that they're playing especially Jack
Black like he was perfect for it and I
thought I thought Jack Black might just
go in with being a little like too over
the top yeah like really just like I'm
gonna go crazy here with my voice work
um but he's like a voice actor it was
like a real performance great work yeah
I mean I agree the physicality of the
animal mixed with their fighting style
and their voice I think that's why this
movie's so unique is those Dynamics
don't always land all three like the
casting was both physical and emotional
and it was the visual of the animal and
I feel like it put you in a universe in
a really unique way well I really
thought that you they usually could have
just done kung fu fight scenes or or
just you know good kicks and punches and
flips sure but they really thought about
how does like a snake move how does a
tiger move how does how do they latch on
to things how does a monkey move and
they they and the animation so like
kinetic throughout yet it was still
dazzling and they would constantly use
that within their choreography yeah of
how specifically these animals would
move and and enhance that height in it
and I thought that was like one of the
smartest choices they could have used so
really how I would say about like The
Incredibles of like only animation could
pull off this with superhero Powers they
managed to do this so it's like well we
have animals so let's really lean into
how these animals would maneuver around
and then yeah like the teamwork I kept
thinking X-Men like how they would fight
with their strengths and coordination
because they've trained for 20 years
yeah and then like especially that
bridge sequence I love the bridge that
might be my favorite scene in the film
is the bridge sequence where they're
using the animation medium and a really
unique way mixed with the animals mixed
with like what we've learned about their
fighting style and then the z-axis is
just bananas like yeah it's doing so
much and I thought it was also a clever
play on the whole Chosen One motif of
how
that's kind of just BS right yeah that
it's really just about belief in
yourself that oh and then the chosen one
stuff tends to come down to that but
there still is a Chosen One quality to
it and this one literally a mirror yeah
this one was like your parents aren't
important right right
thank you Ryan Johnson
gotta tear down your Heroes and find the
hero within anyone could be a hero
what was he I think he's a red panda
what kind of animal is that what is the
name of the Kung Fu Master I don't know
[Music]
what kind of animal my my phone is so
messed up you ever get 10 minutes into
filming a reaction audiencing oh man I'm
starving oh my and then the movies about
food yeah
I was struggling 10 minutes into this
movie I was like oh man I am so hungry
about the beat where he said he dreamed
of food I was like I'm actively dreaming
of food
and I I love that too of how food is his
coping mechanism and he imagines it I
lost a visual and they didn't overdo
that I was afraid once we saw it once
they do it like 10 times like he'd
become food and then be like all these
food like they didn't want to give us
the visualization it is a red panda yeah
yeah oh and that's beautiful
because you're related to pandas so I
like that it's a red panda s's Master as
a father figure even though it's a
separate entity and he's a panda red
panda nicely done like that like that a
lot Interscope you know P Diddy and uh
no that's that's uh Bad Boy Records
who's under scope now
I don't know I think Dre
anyway good for them great music all the
great rap music in this
where's that post credit scene edited on
Avid nice ah and HP they gave credit to
as well which I've never seen
Hewlett-Packard gets them Lucas work
this one Lucas
what a great transition set up the
sequel
yeah I'm definitely gonna eat I'm so I
might go get dumplings
oh I love that
beautiful
oh I'm glad it wasn't more I actually
really like that it's a
metaphorical beauty of the end instead
of being like a joke they should have
set up for the villain well Thanos is
obviously the post-post credit scene
where the the snow lever turns around
and smiles at us because he's collecting
all the Infinity uh you know dumplings
unless you're making a snail oh I hope
this is the villain is a snail I hope
it's a turtle and there's a hair in the
next one was animals uh so I love the
metaphors of this what what did you uh
what was your biggest boy and you judged
me and said I needed to get something
out of this I clearly was missing uh
because it's about me apparently and I
didn't get it either time you said it
which just made the joke
I spent like 70 of that movie judging
myself going like what am I doing I feel
like the I feel like him in the first
half I was just messing around but it
made it so funny I was like what am I
not seeing in my Jedi masks Pride
blinding koi man that's like pride of
what it's just totally
it worked
yeah you're worthy man you gotta just um
you know you're good enough dude I gotta
just be more joyous in my I mean I love
how he eased into it with a relaxation
as well I think there's a sense of of
overthinking that the movie does uh talk
about quite a bit yeah you know
especially that thing in the beginning I
forget what is the water rip I've never
heard that before you've never heard
that that's one of my favorite
meditation Concepts so uh a still water
is the only way you can see your
reflection and the more you overthink
the more the ripples in the water there
are so when you look at Still Water it
allows you to be truth to the visuals so
like if a couple Rebels you can still
discern it but when you're upset and
anxious it's all ripples yeah so like
rain metaphor throwing Rock metaphor
there's a lot of really cool it helps my
brain like cleanse you know take some
medication I think I mean that's the
trick yeah
that sounds like a lot of work I go to a
river no just go to the doctor take a
lot of pills take a bath yeah
no I love the Stillness I also love the
spontaneity of like the split like that
was a really cool moment where it was
like great reveal he let himself such a
good reveal fantastic reveal yeah I I
thought like how he got into it in a
relaxed way and how they kept his
fighting style with that kind of drunken
master fighting was great it was like
the kind of kung fu movies I grow and
I've kind of mentioned it a few times on
this channel there was okay so the arrow
in Jackie Chan blew up in the 90s
um there was also they weren't they
hadn't made it to the states yet but he
was actually the director of the movie
Mr Nice have you seen Mr Nice Guy with
Jackie Chan okay uh you've seen the Ip
Man movies yes you have okay in the
second movie the big guy who he's I
don't know if he remembers like the the
really overweight guy who's like a Kung
Fu Master maybe have not seen the upman
I'm realizing in real time
um I think I've just seen the poster a
lot of times I've seen that when I okay
so Jackie Chan he like he had some of
his moves when we came over here in the
90s and I came over here like he had
some of his films like Rumble in the
Bronx which was dubbed he was having his
movies come over dub before he came out
with rush hour which was American made
and my brother and I we became pretty
obsessed with like Jackie Chan movies
that were actually in Hong Kong so
movies like uh Wheels On Wheels Fearless
hyena things that a lot of people hadn't
seen out here but they were like hard
VHS as you had before yeah and so I
would watch a lot of those and that's
more of what this was reminding me of so
I grew up on that there was like the
umbl films and the Samo hung movies and
they grew up together and samahan has
done a lot of stuff in America so far
but basically
um yeah those are the kind of like Hong
Kong influences and there's like the
Hong Kong fantasy kind of action films
and I've seen like a few of those uh but
those weren't really the thing I was
more like was the things that I feel
more realistic yeah because there's like
that Hong Kong fan it's like like a
Crouching Tiger is a Hong Kong fantasy
um and this I thought was a great
melding of amalgamation of all those
films especially when it came to like
the way how he fought like a relaxed
Warrior of that is someone who's coming
what I thought was impressive about what
they did with Poe was how he did his
fighting style reflected not a Stern
type of disciplinary Warrior it
reflected him as a character as a person
and I thought they really fleshed out
who these characters are through their
physicalities as well you know what I
mean that's not meant by the the voice
acting masking matching the physicality
matching the animal like that's three
layers that I think immediately puts you
in the world faster than a lot of
Animation because you're immediately
like oh this voice is familiar even
though I can't place it and it fits for
the animal which is a weird thing to
think but I'm like that's that animal's
voice yeah he had a Carefree fighting
style yeah if anything he kind of like
that the whole thing about talking like
more water there's a version of this
where it's like oh he kind of Moves Like
Water and sometimes it's an allegory or
a metaphor for how they describe certain
type of fighting styles like you got to
be fluid like water under is a certain
time
yeah and I thought that was amazing of
how they did that because he's fighting
against the snow is it a snow leopard
that's the snow leopard who who they
they are very just you know because
because what I was saying about how it
feels like there's an improvisation to
the fight I there that's something that
I think is under recognized in fight
scenes is how there is it's court it's
choreographed obviously it's
choreography but the whole point of like
a great fight is to not make it look
like it's so rehearsed right and they
managed to do that here with the
animations were just very hard it's
hundreds of hours yeah yeah and they
managed to make it feel like they're
they're improvising throughout and a lot
of times that does come into like when
the snow leopard gets hit by the fire
and dives into it and picks up the fires
using it you know I thought that was
great and so I to me this captured like
the essence of great fight scenes with
beautiful imagery we uh my family grew
up with it was it was a three Sylvester
Stallone
obviously
what age are we yeah uh we had a VHS
that we were recorded three movies off
of like HBO or something it was uh
Rumble in the Bronx Legend the Drunken
Master and then something cop either
super cup super cup yeah so those were
our three big Jackie Chan's growing up
and then as he got to America like we I
discovered more but I remember like
watching those three on the loop and
then next was Jet Li and then Tony jaw
and I remember specifically Jackie Chan
was fun and then gently it was like
stiff but like really precise lines of
quippy and then Tony drop was brutal uh
so it was interesting like to see the
the uh popularity of kung fu or martial
arts changed through those artists and I
feel like I felt like the Jackie Chan
this felt way more like Jackie Chan
because of the fact of How It's like Poe
is there's there's a comedy he's not
perfect he's getting hit all the time
which is Jack James and the way he uses
items around him is very Jackie Chan
um yeah the comedy leniency into his
fighting style felt very Jackie like
there is because like there's drunken
master came out here but a lot of people
don't realize that's that's actually a
sequel oh
um that came out here and and I love
that one the sequel that came out here
and the first one he did was the was
like I think I want to say like 20 years
prior
um and that was the film that made
Jackie Chan super famous in Hong Kong
was the first one he did and that's
where he is being trained to become a
drunken fighter cool uh it's a spiritual
sequel made it here that's yeah and the
seat that the actual sequel then got
dubbed and brought over to the states
cool yeah that's the one that you're
talking about the one with the guy where
he fights again yeah he kicks right yeah
yeah and like the that's all flow yeah
and so this one reminded me of that
first Drunken Master movie come on and
then there's the thing with the I mean
that's kind of like a common Kung Fu
thing when they're fighting with the
food yeah but yeah there was in a couple
of like Jackie Chan I like that even a
couple of the moves were exactly the
moves earlier like there was a couple
frames where they changed the camera
angle so you could see that he was
mirroring the moves that he said he
fought against earlier really enjoyed
that Master learner Master absorber yeah
well hopefully you guys like this I want
to watch the second one I don't I feel
like they could have utilized I hope in
the sequel they use the cast more
because I'm really curious like today
because like Jackie Chan's just chilling
and he's around Jake yeah like like
eight lines and a lot of them were
single words
what's going on does he like not like to
be on a sound booth because he's got
action to do it even like using Angelina
Jolie and Seth Rogue like all these
famous people yeah he's so unnecessary
you guys come in uh Thursday Friday
that's enough that's it just check in
like they really use Jackie Chan
um Ian McShane and then and uh Dustin
Hoff I now remember one of my favorite
press images of all time is Angelina
Jolie was pregnant and and Jack Black
was pushing out his gut and they both
have the same size oh really and it's in
front of all the uh the panda stuff oh
so it's the panda belly Jack Black belly
Angelina Jolie belly but I completely
forgot that image it's so good but I
hope because they went on tour around
the world that they're in the next one
more I hope they use them more because
yeah they didn't see like David Cross
was kind of used in the David Cross they
each got a little section but each
section was shorter like I feel like
they all got their Shining Moment but
like moment I mean it makes for good
trailers right like when you stand for
billing yeah exactly it's a poster
exactly it is a poster that's what I
meant for like trailers yeah and good
billing for Kevin Bacon because now
we're all closer because they were all
together
I mean I do want to watch the next one I
got a lot out of that I It's tricky
because the legend was so big like I've
heard about that movie for years and I
was really worried that I was like
because How to Train Your Dragon it's
one of the few anime movies that like to
me is timeless and perfect and I'd put
this like as something I'd love to show
my kids as well as adults like this is
one of those that really lands for all
ages and demographic I mean not to
mention too that it also I mean I've
seen a pretty good amount of anime at
this point in my life now and so I think
about a lot of those and then uh there's
even like avatar The Last Airbender
reference there's a lot of like this
this is just like influence Bonanza yeah
and in a way that manages to not feel
over convoluted and in fact I wish it
was kind of longer yeah see some of the
carrot the other characters and watch
how that was Dynamics keep it at the
heart and center of
sifu
is that was that just what he's called
who which one
but keep at the heart and Center Shifu
and I'm like how you point out in the
reaction when they they flip in the
Dynamics of like I need you to stay so I
can train you I love that that way and
that was all through dialogue I really
like that you know in every movie there
has to be the conflict switch where you
have the unlikable uh trainer or Master
he has to find a reason to want and
usually it's like more cliche like
there's usually something that's like
obligatory that it's like well he's not
really forgiving him but this was just
dialogue where they were both fighting
for the same thing from opposite
directions it really wasn't the way I
like that all right what would you give
it out of a percentage that's how I
write out of any percentage I out of 100
what do you give this is how I like to
write things koi I'm gonna go
88 88 to 91. you know what I was gonna
say
I was gonna say 89. yeah yeah 80 it's 91
somewhere in there but like definitely
in the in the near 90. yeah I think it's
like a perfect family film now let's
compare our rating
to
Rotten Tomatoes
oh there's a fourth one coming out oh
in 2024 we're not oh there's a
poster we can join oh it's in March
that's soon March 2024 oh my God 10 and
a half months we should have waited but
now we can watch all of them before
now we can do it oh damn these all got
good ratings holy crap hey we were on
the money though look at that even Kung
Fu Panda 2's out of that 80s one percent
that's rare for a sequel 87 87 yeah we
were running the money there higher than
the audience score
I mean that's 250 000 people yeah it is
versus yeah
that's pretty solid Good Sense 250 000
people uh 2008 so this movie is uh what
17 years old
I feel like I've seen some of it
I'm gonna be really honest with you guys
the kids movie so I want to be a little
bit careful here and I've mentioned this
in some other videos
from around I want to say 2008 to 2012.
no I go a little higher 2008 to like
2016.
I had a lot of I was primarily
functioning morning noon and night
of a lot of flowers
you know what I mean so you had a
different experience
there were some parts where I was like I
had to question like had I seen this but
this is familiar but I didn't know that
that happens to be quite a quite a lot
where I'm like I don't know if I've seen
this or have I've Just Seen imagery so I
was working at a movie theater until
2008 2009 and I was worried I'd seen it
because I was working at the theater
when this came out but I think it was on
my way out so I don't I didn't catch it
I was a little worried because I might
have seen like a minute or two like
checking on someone but like yeah had
not seen this one like I I watched
Tucker and Dale vs Evil with Roxy and I
was like I know I saw this but I don't
remember anything First Watch I was just
like totally uh yeah there was a period
where I know I can honestly tell you
like sometimes I watch movie watch a
movie on my own time because I it was a
bad experience of no there's a reason I
don't remember a lot what a gift First
Watch partner and I was like yep nope
taking it back none of this familiar to
me whatsoever like this is like a brand
new experience and that's what was
happening here when I was watching it
too I was like I honestly don't know if
I've put this on before well I want to
watch the next one so yeah let's do it I
for sure definitely I don't I can't I
I've I don't think I've even glimpsed at
all what what happens 2011 I guess so
yeah I definitely wasn't I have not seen
the next one and 81 is pretty pretty
reassuring for a sequel
all right sweet all right guys thanks
for being here koi thank you my friend
ladies and gentlemen we'll see you all
soon thank you to the sponsor of this
video you know that sponsor that one
that one there
foreign